China's League of Legends league is
canceled until further notice all
because of a deadly virus that's been
making headlines this is a very serious
very crazy story so let's just get right
into it all right so first the eSports
part of this news week two of the LPL
has been indefinitely delayed because of
the corona virus which is a deadly virus
that's been ravaging parts of China and
we'll get to more about that in a moment
the LPL was already on break for a Lunar
New Year but when news of the virus
began to spread and the virus itself
began to spread the LPL chose to delay
week two of games indefinitely in order
to better protect the health and safety
of their fans and players notably the
LDL which is China's version of the
Academy League is also delayed
indefinitely as for when things will be
back well we reached out to Riot Games
and got this comment our team in China
is working closely with authorities
there and will continue to monitor the
situation on a daily basis there are a
few more eSports events that have been
or could be impacted by the Chinese
government's reaction to the corona
virus outbreak first will be w es g's
csgo a packed finals in Macau which was
canceled last Wednesday the event was
supposed to run from February 16th to
18th and W ESG has yet to announce if
they'll be holding a replacement event
elsewhere there are also three overwatch
league teams based in China the Chengdu
hunters the Shanghai dragons and the
Hangzhou spark who are all scheduled to
host games in China this year some home
stands are even coming up as soon as
February none of the teams nor Blizzard
has made any statements about whether
they'll be delaying those home stands or
canceling them entirely or continuing as
planned so what is the corona virus well
the virus we're hearing about right now
is actually a specific strain of corona
virus one that we've never encountered
before many fear the situation is
already far worse than government
officials are telling them in Hong Kong
for instance where they still remember
the huge toll from the SARS virus if
you've ever heard of SARS that was
actually another novel strain of corona
virus that we had never encountered
before when it broke out in the early
2000s and if you haven't heard of it or
are too young to remember the outbreak
it was a disease that spread out of Asia
in the early 2000s
killed about 774 people mostly in China
and Hong Kong SARS is another thing that
I'll get back to a little bit later in
this video anyway most coronaviruses
began in animals and this particular
strain is believed to have originated at
a seafood market mu Han which is the
sixth largest city in China this
specific food market was closed on
January 1st after the first symptoms
were discovered on December 8th
however some reports from Chinese
researchers have found that 13 of the 41
first cases of this strain of crota
virus may not have originated in the
market so it's still relatively unclear
where this virus originated anyway the
World Health Organization received its
first reports from Chinese officials on
December 31st when they reported that
there was an outbreak in muha a few
weeks later there were 600 confirmed
cases in China and 18 deaths on January
23rd the Chinese government expanded the
quarantine from Wuhan to Guan gong and
Asia these three cities account for
nearly 20 million people that's more
than the entire population of the
Netherlands if you want a little bit of
perspective what you're seeing here is
really being replicated all over the
country people are worried about leaving
their homes and they're concerned so the
government has been taking a many more
aggressive measures to try to contain
what they've described as the
strengthening of virus within the
quarantine zone people are not allowed
to take any public transit a lot of the
city is on lockdown supermarkets have
been pretty much cleaned out of all
their food and people have been urged to
stay indoors and avoid public places as
of recording there have been nearly
3,000 confirmed cases and at least 80
deaths as a result of the virus that's
now being referred to as 2019 and CoV
those numbers are according to the New
York Times we've also learned that the
virus can now transfer from person to
person not just animal to person which
is what's led to stuff like the
quarantines and of course the LPL
delaying games given that all their
games happen in public places we already
mentioned the quarantine in Wuhan a city
that's larger than New York but the
Chinese government has also canceled
inter province and bus services they've
suspended tours within China and the
Hong Kong government has declared a
state of emergency and closed schools
for at least three weeks things are
getting very serious the US government
has also begun screening people coming
in from Wuhan
to the states and the government is also
on getting American out of LA starting
tonight we're going to begin screening
passengers arriving from Wuhan
into the United States at the three
airports that see the majority of those
passengers the airports are JFK San
Francisco and Los Angeles and one of the
english-language casters for the LPL
munch tweeted out that he and the
majority of the English language
LPL caster desk are leaving China when
we go back to our own country where you
go and you go back to I've been in the
UK UK Australia the Irish safety worried
about the reaction to this strain of the
coronavirus is relatively similar to
SARS which as I mentioned was a strain
of the corona virus that spread across
Asia and around the world in the early
2000s now researchers eventually found
that SARS originated in back from the
Yunnan Province of China but at the end
of the day it was a relatively rare
disease and was declared contained in
2003 pretty shortly after the outbreak
was first reported one of the major
outbreak locations for SARS outside of
China was Toronto which is where I'm
from and I remember that people were
extremely concerned during the outbreak
now we're in a similar situation with a
lot of panic around the globe and people
working to help people which has led to
things like the LTL getting caught up in
the situation notably former pro player
and EDG coach clearlove is from Wuhan
and it appears according to the
translations at least that he's
streaming from there right now on top of
that the inter province bus network is
down right now due to the quarantines so
it may be difficult for LPL players to
get back to their team's headquarters
when the LPL starts back up again it's
all very new says the deputy director of
China's National Health Commission Lieb
in our knowledge is limited and the
epidemic is not in control
we haven't actually been able to confirm
if there are any other players in the
LPL who are in the quarantine zone or
are otherwise affected so we're just
hoping that everyone is
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]